uh i would like to welcome everyone once
again so myself uh nithyanand sharma
and uh uh i am a senior product manager
in gramas life sciences and i take care
of
this 10x genomics portfolio
uh which is a a company which is based
in uh us
and uh they are the global leader in
this area so using the their
workflow and other stuff we will try to
learn uh what exactly this application
is
and then we can take up some questions
from your end
to answer i will be happy to answer them
so let's start the presentation let me
use my laser pointer
okay
so
all tissues are heterogeneous and
complex so that is the foremost
we can say
complexity that is
we observe when we see any any tissue
sample which is coming from human and
which is common to all the organisms
which are multicellular in nature
and if you see
every
cell type in a tissue in an organ has a
specific role and when there is a
deviation in those roles
then it leads to some specific diseases
or if there is some deficiency or
particular cell type function then also
we encounter various diseases so
whatever data right now we are
generating is the genomic data is almost
constant what we say
so that is like mendelian inheritance or
uh where diseases caused by a particular
point mutation can be picked up by ngs
technologist and we can say that yes
but the real aspect is the functional
aspects the functional aspect is
happening at rna and protein level
where the enzymes are being synthesized
or functional units are there that are
going to do the metabolic activities and
those deviation leads to the diseases so
if you
uh can go through the human cell atlas
program
this is a program
initiated by science good initiative
that is to
catalog the all the human cells present
in a body
uh and also find out the causes of
different diseases that are
that are encountered in the human we can
say population
so so this is
where the signal set technologies are
helping to these initiative so that the
right type of data can be generated
now uh
i think from ud presentation and from
asia's presentation you people
understood that
we have to sequence our dna
element or we can say dna entity
so here you can see the forward read and
the reverse read that means something we
are sequencing from this and from this
end and to sequence that
uh
what we need
so on illumina sequencer we need uh two
adapters on both the ends
uh we can see here read one primer read
to primer so that will typically leads
to the sequencing of the insert or the
dna insert then we have i5 and i7
indexes so these indexes are useful when
you want to do multiple samples in a one
go
so this index reads will help you to
de-multiplex the data
and apart from this you can also see the
p5 and p7 primer adapters so these
adapters are an inherent part of the
illumina sequencer where
they will help those dna elements
binding to the flow cell and performing
the clone and amplification which udit
has just shown in the video
now
right now we are able to segregate data
sample wise yes
whatever rate coming from which sample
now if you want to sequence it
to the cell
then you can see there is
i have to add a cell barcode to that
element so this is like the need
then
i will add the other press uh upstream
in the downstream of those sequences so
now i'll come to know
which sample the read is coming and from
which cell the read is coming so sample
also demultiplexing and the cell data is
also getting demultiplexed so this is
the purpose of the signal cell
technology
and at the same time your need is to
count the rna that we have captured so
the counting is happening based on
unique molecular identifier
and rest of the element will be same so
this is going to help you to tag
whatever rna you capture
from the sample give you unique
molecular tags so that the pcr artifact
could be removed and easily we can do
the counting part so ultimately what you
will have how many molecules we captured
from which cell you captured and from
which sample
the data is coming and these are the
sequencing read that is the standard to
the illumina sequencing chemistry
so which gene
how many copy of those gene or molecule
we captured from which cell was captured
and from which sample we are capturing
so sample indexes are just to multiplex
multiple samples for sequencing run
hope this is almost clear to everyone
now how the data looks like on a disney
plot this is
a plot where
you can see
different dots are there so each dot is
a cell
and based on their gene expression
pattern or closure they will be
clustered on this disney plot allotment
you can see the erythrocytes are there
some neurons are there and all the
neurons have different uh clusters so
that means they do different functions
and they have differences in their
gene expression pattern so this data is
coming from 10 000 mouse brain derived
from the cortex hippocampus ventricular
jones and embryon from the embryonic day
18
and all the major subpopulation we are
able to pick it up
now if it is a disease sample you will
be able to see some deviations in the
gene expression pattern and the disease
specific gene will be expressing in some
of the population not all the population
so this is like we are adding one more
dimension to my ngs data that is from
which cell the rna is coming
now
uh it is like you have to do tissue
dissociation to get the single cell
suspension
now people working on tissues demanded
that no we don't want to disrupt the
tissue we want to map the data on the
tissue image only or the tissue surface
or tissue section only so
then
another technology that is again from
tennis genomics is helping to map the
data
to the location on the tissue at one to
tensor resolution right now which is
like in the next year you will get a
single cell resolution so here
if you see
this is a histology image many people
are aware of sectioning the tissue
placing on the slide
doing a imaging or a chinese staining
and then taking the image and then
morphologically find out what cell types
which tissue type where exactly the
variation is and the pathologist see
where the cancer cell is
or oncopathology where the cancer and
normal cells how the interactions are
happening but that is just based on
those morphological features but
ultimately what is happening at the gene
expression level we are limited to one
or two or even three or four markers
only not we are not getting the story of
rest of the rna what they are doing or
the rest of the gene what they are doing
at different location so now
this technology is going to help you
capture the rna spot mislocation wise
and giving a specific bar code like the
cell bar code we are giving and
ultimately when you sequence the data
you will be able to map it to the
location so here you can see the
uh different uh the uh like cell types
or we can say tissue types are
clustering together and ultimately all
these clusters are going to be mapped at
different location so you can see the
feature or or the expression feature of
this image is matching the morphological
image that means the technology is
robust and is able to deliver you
the right type of data and able to
capture the right amount of rna from
every spot and then
map it to the location based on the
using the biomatic software
now
it has been already uh understood by the
scientific community that these
technology will bring
a big promise in the clinical domain i
can say and uh that that's why
science has recognized this method as a
breakthrough of the year in 2018 and
when multiple data from the same sample
you are
generating like some chromatin data some
genome data protein data methylation
data transcriptome data from the same
cell that was recognized as the nature's
method of the year in 2019
and uh already this technology is being
i think the scientist has recognized is
at the top 10 innovation
from 2015 to 20 onwards every year there
is a new addition to this portfolio and
it it became the method of the uh the
top innovation by the scientist magazine
so you'll be seeing uh some more
products from tennis genomics which will
be related at top 10 innovations every
year
uh the publication number is already
increasing exponentially i can say and
right now 3000 plus publications are
there mostly in top rated journals
nature cell science uh so the the people
are generating uh the right type of data
from the right type of sample
and write biological story they are able
to decipher
from their samples and ultimately they
are getting published in high rated
journals
now
when it comes to the story of
where where how far is the clinic story
and how far it is
like
ngs technologies or these single cell
technologies will be hitting the clinics
so ultimately the story always start
with the r d or research and definitely
many labs have adopted these
technologies including the pharma
companies and we are able to see
that
some
inputs and outputs are
getting uh generated from
these
new technological you know wasted
technology from this new technological
innovations and you can able to see that
better profiling or
of the cancer samples we are able to do
we are able to understand what exactly
transcriptome differences are happening
in the relapse even if we are doing a
cell based therapy what is the
performance of those cell which are
infused in the
in the patient
so those things we can monitor using
these technologies so ultimately yes
the story has already started and some
publications are in this area
and
people are trying to generate or
standardize this technology so that they
can offer a specific test and some
companies are there
in this area at the same time
now coming to
the drug discovery journey which is the
clinical aspect what we know
uh so uh starting from its uh first
objective target identification uh the
the technology is going to help in a
bigger way because we are able to
catalog each and every cell and what
exactly it is doing in the same in that
sample so so we are able to understand
the targets then uh performance of the
drugs
in terms of preclinical studies so we
are able to do those aspects so you can
see some publications and understanding
the t-cell expand expansion in the tumor
infiltration the clinical response
and some
here you can see the clinically relevant
core needle biopsies for evaluation of
tumor immune
cell interaction so all this uh is based
on a single cell sequencing technologies
people are doing automatic clinical
research is there and the clinical trial
is also there at the same time so pre
clinical clinical research and trials
in every phase you can see
this technology is going to help
the user to generate the right type of
data what they need for their
experiments
now as i told uh already
the
broad adoption is there from all the top
20 biopharma companies which right now
you can see on the screen
uh
you are able to
you can just pick up like
gsk is the biggest brand rosh is already
a very big brand gentech the rosh is
like
even though they don't have these
technologies but they adopt the
technology which are upcoming and i have
bigger promise in the pharma domain and
uh push their r d in those directions
similarly estrogenic guys there's an
office there
lily is there mark is the takeda biogen
uh
ham is there on the novo nordisk so all
those big pharma company have already
invested in these methods to generate
the clinical data for from their trials
now
uh
at the same time
this single cell technology is going to
replace and complement i will say
uh to the traditional methods by which
we wanted to understand the genomics we
want to do the crispr screening we want
to do rna sequencing we want to do t
cell b cell receptor studies we want to
perform chromatin studies and we want to
do protein expression studies so there
are different various methods that is
being used now of one way one workflow
is a single side technology which can
help you generate this diverse data
using ngs sequencer in a more simpler
way as compared to multiple platforms
multiple equipment you are using to
generate different type of data from the
sample and it has also been promising or
has promised that you can generate
two or three types of data or four types
of data from the same cell which uh
practically impossible by any other
technology right now
now
coming to the complete solution uh what
we have in the single cell area is the
instrument
so you need a specific instrument so
that
the single cell library can be prepared
and this equipment needs the consumable
part which is also provided and
manufactured by tennis genomics you can
see different regions are there the chip
is there and this is for vision slides
to generate the data from the tissue
section
and then we have the software part so
once the data is out how to analyze and
visualize the data so this part is
totally free from tennis genomics anyone
can download the software
and install it and
learn the
pick some data sets and start analyzing
the data at the same time so there is no
need to
get any license for these softwares
now
as i told that we are able to do
multiple aspects of a biological sample
in which you can see there are
publication in the area of crispr
you can see multiple publication you can
see area epigenomics where you can see
some publications there the gene
expression is already the the story
started with this and you can see
multiple
applications or publications are there
where people are generating data from
the rna of individual cells and then you
can see high thorough immune profiling
which is also right now in the covered
area very very important and
using this technology they got some
breakthrough
and apart from this the high thermal
protein screening uh you can see some
publications are there where
some estro
erythrosclerotic plaques and some other
uh
mr people uh
systemic lupus is there so people are
generating so
what the type of data which was needed
previously
because of technical limitations they
were not generating but now the
technological limitations has been
overcome and people are exploring all
those aspects of the
biology consumer so here you can see
acquired resistance cancer resistance
was understood by
the transcriptional loss of class 1 hla
so all those aspects are very very
important and single cell technology is
going to help in that area
now how exactly we have to generate this
huge
biological data at single cell
resolution
so what is the background uh behind this
so if you see uh 10x product lines are
basically uh fall into four categories
first at in the single cell one is gene
expression uh immune profiling attack
and attack plus gene expression so
this uh gene expression anemia profiling
have
more additional feature in which you are
able to do cell surface protein
and also we offer a targeted panel so
that you can save the cost on sequencing
part
because sequencing uh the whole
transcriptome uh sometimes is a
challenging
when you want to
limit your budget
so in that way the targeted panel can
reduce the sequencing cost up to 80
percent
now cell surface protein means you can
generate the data of the protein marker
or surface marker similar to what people
are generating using flow data
so flow and genomic data or
transcription data from the same sample
can be generated in one workflow then
people are in the area of crispr
profiling having uh perturbations to be
done uh because of those crystal guide
rna what gene expression changes are
happening so we are able to link both
the data in a single shot
so crispr screening is more streamlined
and more productive i can say
and then we have cell plex for gene
expression uh product line so in this
the cell plex essay you can
pool up to 12 samples in one
reaction
so you will be able to save the cost of
library preparation when you are doing a
cellplex essay at the same time limiting
the number of cells but some application
don't need screening of lot many cells
so such applications can be easily
fitted and also
you can save the cost
then
coming the antigen specificity which is
a very much important aspect of any t
cell so my t is a tcr sequence or this t
cell is binding to which antigen so this
is feasible by
another company imedex that provides the
reagents of
a class 1 class 2 represented antigens
mst represented antigen
the dextromer technology so once you
incubate this with the diesel population
so we come to know which tcr are binding
to our specific antigens
now
this is happening
the data is being captured by the beads
so this beads are very very important
the gel beads what we uh the tennis
technology so how these primers so this
is like a primer delivery agent you can
call
and these beads have specific primers
for every application so if you see the
gene expression one
so in the end you can see there are
three primers are there but in the end
you can see the polydt capture sequence
one and capture sequence to two so poly
dt is definitely is for is going to
capture the mrna
capture sequence one and two
sorry
are going to capture the
crispr data or the cell surface data of
the same cell and the umi i already
explained that is going to do the
counting application and tennis bar code
is going to help you to
demultiples the data at individual cell
level so from which cell
that data is captured or that
molecule is captured that we come to
know and read one will be the part of
the illumina primers so likewise this
this primers are delivered to individual
cells and ultimately they are going to
capture the molecules
rna or those crispr or those cells of
the protein
dna barcodes
now
this is happening at the three prime end
in the immune profiling since we are
sequencing tcr in the bcr our purpose is
to attach the 10x barcode and the umi to
the five prime end of the mrna which is
feasible by the target switch elbow
technology so this is going to help uh
to attach at the five prime end so that
we can sequence the full length tcr and
the bcr of the immune cells that would
be cells in the t cells
now for the attack data that is the
genomic data that is also a dynamic we
can say when a cell is
working at the genome level
some portions of those dna are open and
some are closed euchromatin and
heterochromatin what we can call in a
simple term so uh whatever open regions
are there so those signals are being
captured by this
read one complementary dna sequences and
we are using a transposes technology to
cut down and tag those open chromatin
region of individual nuclei and
ultimately
you will be able to generate at single
cell resolution the epigenomics of that
particular cell
and
last one
is attack plus gene expression which was
launched last year and a lot many
publications are coming up everything
this because it is able to
capture the chromatin of the same nuclei
and the rna of the same nuclei so the
epigenomic landscape of the same cell
and transcriptomic landscape of the same
cell so how they are interrelated and
how correlations can be made very easily
without any
difficult bioinformatics
pipeline so such such uh
new uh solution is welcomed by the
scientific community and lot money data
has been generated using this technology
so thing to remember here is
uh we are capturing
the molecules from a cell using a bead
so this is a functional bead and every
application has a specific
molecular signatures on their beads
now
uh
where exactly you have to use these
reagents so this reagent
to be used on either chromium controller
or chromium x or ix where i can see this
is going to do low throughput and
standard third foot
and
will be coming to know what exactly
those who put standard third and high
throughput technology is uh so chromie
max is going to support the ht kits and
ix needs to be upgraded so that it can
do ht
kits
now
this slide will give you an idea
about
what exactly we have to do
to convert cells into libraries
or sequencing libraries so
first
job is to prepare the cell suspension so
we have to do counting we have to do
qc of the cell
whether they are
what we say
exactly
in terms of
uh
reliability
viability of those cells the number of
cells the size of the cells the debris
so all those things we say that it
should be debris
the
appropriate amount of cells has to be
there for every sample and then we
prepare enzyme mix similar to our enzyme
mix and we add the counted cell into
that particular
sample
in the meantime we have to assemble the
chip on a aluminium
cassette so here you can see that there
are eight channels so this means we can
process eight samples at a time and you
can see there are row one two and three
so this indicates what exactly uh where
exactly we have to load the reagents so
first job is to prepare the cell and
enzyme mix and load it in the row one
so all the eight samples have been
loaded
now in the row 2 you can add the gel
bits so these are individually packed
gel beads so what we see in the previous
slide the gel beads and ultimately you
will be able to add in the row 2
or you have to add and in the top well
you will be loading the oil so
this is like the whole uh
fitting step that you have to do on this
particular chip
and if you don't want to use all the
wells so you can fill the rest of the
wells or empty wells with the
50 glycerol
and then you will have to add a
gasket on this this is again provided by
10x and ultimately you will be
placing it on in either chromium
controller or in a chromium x system or
ix system and you can see here what
exactly is happening in a video the
beads are moving the reagents are going
to be mixed and ultimately one cell is
going to capture
randomly in these reactions
so
this is the cell that you just saw that
that got captured in that reaction so
this is happening continuously
and millions of partitions are being
created and
a few of them will sell have cells so
like if you have loaded 16 000 cells or
17 000 cells then almost 10 000
partitions or these reactions will have
cells and rest of will be empty so that
we can remove the doublet
efficiency of this particular workflow
because
if you load more cells the chances of
two cells in one reaction will be high
so to reduce that we generate
sufficiently large amount of partitions
or empty partitions
and ultimately you are able to see that
cell is getting captured randomly in
these reactions and everyone has its own
10x bar code so we are able to tag
the molecules of those cells
now
uh this slide is ultimately the
biochemistry of the workflow you can see
so likewise you will be able to see if
you see under microscope the cells are
captured the bead is there
and you can see here
the cell is also there so this is the
reaction entity
it has rt enzyme other
lysis reagents which are going to lies
these beads and the cells and ultimately
all the primers and the rna will be in a
reaction
uh or we can say independent reaction
and then we have to collect it and
take it in the pcr tube
and do a rt pc a step so in this step
only
the content of the
reactions are getting barcoded so once
you bar code then you can use a recovery
agent you will be using a recovery agent
so that it can be disrupted and uh the
pool of this barcode its tdna will be
purified and ultimately you will be
converting into a sequenceable library
which we have just discussed
these are the features of those
sequential libraries so you can see
tennis bar code emi
the quality how what we captured and
from the other end we are reading the
sequence of the gene
so we come to know which gene it is
which sample from the indexes uh how
many copy of those molecules we captured
and tennis barcode tell us from which
cell it is captured so ultimately that
becomes the input on the illumina
machine
here you can see nexiq novaseq
but it is compatible with all the
platforms but depending on the amount of
data you can choose the right platform
now
once the data is out then you will have
to use a cell ranger pipeline where you
can see
ultimate goal is to
catalog the cell numbers the gene
and the feature if you capture some
feature and ultimately do a
counting in the cell and put across like
how many molecules will be captured for
each cell
for each gene and ultimately this will
be very huge matrix and to simplify it
in a visualization way
you will using the loop browser the
output file is a silo file
which will be used on this software so
that you can see the
what type of cells are present in a
sample
and these are some markers that let you
know uh catalyze catalogue those cells
or name those cells and you can see the
t cell tumor cells so we can see some
occur top to wave
break five and ccna2 and cases are there
monocytes are there exhausted helper
teasers are there and the normal t-cells
are there which are cd3-e marker so
ultimately you will be able to see
the whole heterogeneity of your sample
type depending on the sample you're
working on
now the next slide is the summary of the
single cell workflow so starting
material will be a cell on the nuclei or
nuclei
you have the system
to do the library preparation so you
have various kits depending on your
experiment you have to choose either any
one of the kits from this then once you
prepare the library you will be doing
the sequencing part and then comes the
data analysis where cell ranger and loop
browser are going to help you the data
analysis
now let's see some uh
some
experiments before that i think chromium
x update i want to give you
so
the chromium controller or standard
system it will be capturing 10 000 cells
maximum per channel the whereas the
chromium
con
x with their sdk
will be able to help you capture up to
20 000 per channel and at the same time
16 samples at a time instead of eight
samples at a time which i just saw in
the previous slide
and uh the capture efficiency is still
the 65 percent multiplet rate is low
around point five percent for one
thousand cells
and uh it is able to reduce the overall
cost of the budget by 60
and if you're doing a cell multiplexing
you are able to do up to 750 000 cells
in a one run
so it is very much highly
uh
like flexible system which supports the
existing kits also and the newest
tickets so how it is achieved so they
have
uh do a smart work where the gel beads
are being used for
uh the
and 2b these two are the sample rows and
gel bit is common and the top will and
the bottom well are the collection wells
and ultimately
you are able to see
that in this diagrammatic way the gel
bead one is going to four channels and
enzymes or cell mix is
moving through two channels and
ultimately these two channels are ending
up in the top and the bottom well so ten
thousand cells from one end and the from
the other end also ten thousand cells
the total twenty thousand cells we are
capturing in both the uh top and the
bottom recovery wells
so this way we are they are achieving uh
doubling the number of samples per
channel and also doubling the number of
cells captured per channel so ultimately
it is four times we are able to do
the capture capturing number of cells
now
as i told that lte our low throughput
kit is there standard kit is there sdk
it is there separate skate is there and
surplex hd kit is there so if you see
the low throughput is supporting 1000
per channel standard supporting uh 10
000
maximum
st supporting 20 000 and if you're doing
supplex on a standard workflow you're
able to do 30 000 subs per
channel and same thing if you're doing
circlex on hd chip you are still
doubling up to 60 000 cells per channel
now
in terms of total capacity of the
chip
like lt can do eight samples that means
eight thousand cells per uh
run
standard can do uh again eight thousand
then it is eighty thousand cells and if
you are doing ht one so it can do three
thou three lakh twenty thousand cells
and if you're doing cell plex standard
that will lead to 240 000 cells and if
you're doing cellplex hd that will give
you 960 000 cells that means close to
million cells so that is like million
cell story you can create using uh
like in a very short span of time using
x chromium x system with circlex essay
now
uh
as the things are
moving forward
what is we have observed or dennis has
observed as
before 2005
people were publishing data of 100 cells
and more than that and then slowly
2010 15 the story had just started where
people are doing lot many cell samples
we can say
uh million cell samples are coming up in
this after 2020
uh i begin between 2019 and 2020 and
still going on
and at the same time uh the number of
reported cell types are also going uh
increasing when you
catalog more number of cells definitely
you will find more rear cell population
so those findings are also coming up so
ultimately the demand
or the or the user needs these these
methods so that they can catalog each
and every cell of their sample in a cost
effective way so this this 10x is going
to help in in that way
now
where is the real application if you
want to see the discovery translational
and the clinical research
if you see
this is a data of a cancer
sample lung cancer sample
where you can see there is a one two
three and four these are four different
types of sample are there so you can see
the yellow one on the category the
different different
colors so that means they have some
differences in the cell types and
ultimately if you see the cell type
based on their uh whatever function is
there so you can say cancer one so here
is also cancer
here also cancer and these are the
myelite population so if you see these
two cancers are very different and
coming from two different samples so
that means the heterogeneity is very
very huge what we wanted to
understand of any cancer sample then in
the developmental biology stage or any
any developmental uh functional aspects
you can see
from where the cells are going and
ending up to which cell type so all
those tragic trees you can do and
construct the developmental hierarchy
and trace the disease evolution at the
same time the cell linear relationship
can be done
and at the same functional aspects are
there
where
in a particular specific cell population
you can see
if you on and off a particular gene and
do the treatment pretreatment and then
recurrence is there then exactly what
why it is happening so all the stories
you can just understand using single set
technology you'll be able to define the
pathway the network effects you were
able to do whatever discovery in terms
of regulatory network are happening in a
cell
and also correlate the specific
phenotypes outcome why this phenotype is
happening so ultimately this is like
going into more deeper uh and generating
a right
type of data from your samples
now this is example where
the
need of the technology why we need this
technology
is is explanatory or self-explanatory
which
was not evident by any other flow data
or any other specific because
we don't have any marker for those rare
cell populations
and
that's why we need to generate data from
whatever gene they are expressing
simplest way to capture the rna of every
cell and then generate the sequencing
part so here this is the data of a
lung cell population
where uh
what they were doing
they found a very rare cell population
which they termed as a innocence and
when
during the data analysis they found
this was only 5.5 of the cell
but the importance was there because
they are contributing to the fifty
percent of the lung cftr so whatever
gene expression suppose you're doing
real time pcr from this particular
sample
so whatever uh curve is there the fifty
percent is contributed by this point
five percent so the whole story of these
people who were doing the cftr uh
clinical trials or drug development who
focused on the ciliated cells now move
to the
this cell population and then uh now
they will be focusing on the cell
population to develop the trust because
this is the
this is the expression center of those
cftr genes
so that is the story was turned upside
down using the signals and technology
and ultimately that was established in
mouse and human where those cell
population are in a very limited number
and the clinical trials and studies have
been shifted completely to different
direction as compared to what they were
managing right now
so this is the importance of finding the
rare cell population or the target
cell population against which i want to
develop a drug because now people are
doing some research or the medicine such
as mature based on antibody based
delivery but ultimately i want to see
where the to which cell i want to
deliver my drug
and what method i can use to deliver the
drug
what kind of receptors are there on that
particular cell
so this is going to be uh available
using uh these technologies
now in the coveted one
what this user have done
uh the ball fluid was used so this
bottle fluid was
uh ultimately
collected from
nine to 18 days after first symptom
and three recovered mild cases were seen
and six severe cases
and some publicly available single cell
hardness sequencing data from eight
normal
lung samples were done
and ultimately
what exactly if you see
this is the bar fluid from mild cohort
and the severe cohort
and
the 10x genomics was done
single cell rna data was generated
they also did the tcr or the
dcr sequencing of t cell population and
do the mathematic analysis
so this is the overall uh if you see
they have grouped the
1 2 and 3 4 that means the different
cell types
and ultimately if you see just by
visualization
effect or just by visualizing the
healthy control the pattern of different
cells are totally getting shift to some
other cell types
and this here the severe is totally
different from the mild one
though the in the mild also there is a
shift but severe one you can see there
is a
more recruitment of other cell types so
ultimately this means the something is
happening at the cellular level and then
the different
cell population are getting
increased
in the severe patient and that is the
cause of the severity of the disease and
when they also see the
expression of specific uh
genes that are responsible for uh what
we say
um
[Music]
cell this one what we call
uh
uh
in terms of what technical term is uh uh
sorry i'm just avoiding this one uh
relative inflammations so
fc1 and spp yeah
no
problem yes this is a lot of information
we are also
getting so
it's all right
thank you
uh meanwhile if anyone has any questions
please put it in the chat and we'll
cover it towards the end of the session
yeah i'm back
yes yes go ahead yeah
so these are the specific genes that
they found that there was high
expression in the
severe patient
you can see the sixth patient
and this particular gene was
not expressed in that particular
patients
whereas they were completely expressed
or highly expressed in the healthy and
the mild one so these are the markers
that they found that are responsible for
cytokines storm and other stuff that we
uh found in the covet severe patient
and when they analyze the t cell
populations
they found that the clonotype diversity
you can see the
red one is uh only one clonotype two to
five you can see the green one and more
than five is the
blue one so in the
moderate one uh you can see there was a
expansion of those uh
clones of cd
t-cell population specifically
expressing a specific markers
and that lead to the
we can say
more
equipped
the patient is when the diversity is
more to manage the infection so
ultimately this was not happening in the
severe cohort we can see a very limited
cell population
that was there but there was no
clonotype expansion that was happening
which was required that particular to
manage the disease and moderate
in the moderate patient we are able to
see that expansion happening so
a lot many stories and what exactly cell
populations are working
in a milder cohort and in the severe
cohort we can figure it out using the
signal cell technology which we were
completely missing
when we are doing normal ngs or normal
flow or any other workflow where the
singles are resolution of data was not
getting generated
now coming to the next slide is a very
important one i can say uh i will try to
explain it to the listeners uh is
busy but in a simple way just first you
see
this particular one where you can see
antigen is there there is a dna bar code
there is a biotin and there is a
streptavidin so this is uh to verify
those labeled cell population so this is
to be used to
incubate it with the b cell population
that are expressing different uh
antibodies and then you can see
that are getting added to the
particular uh staining method or we have
done and then based on those
pe fluoropro or phycoedition for probe
we are sorting those
uh population and ultimately uh this has
to be taken as an input
in the 10x workflow and you are able to
capture two data one is what antigen is
bound to the cell
based on that barcode data we generate
and then we are able to sequence the
antibody of that particular b cell so we
are doing the antibody sequencing and
which antigen it is bound so ultimately
in this table they just saw they have
just
shown a particular screening of the
nine antigens
hiv and flu to find the normal
neutralizing antibodies which is now
common for covid also
if you see they found that some
antibodies are binding to only one type
of antigen
some are binding to more than uh
two more than one antigens so these are
the number of those clonotypes they
discovered
and ultimately they identify 124 clones
combining
across four or more antigens so these
chrome clones will be
we can say pharmaceutically important
because they have neutralizing effect
on four and more antigens and that can
be used in a
uh
in a broader way to treat a specific or
or manage the specific disease because
they have broad neutralizing effect so
only one antibody or chlorotype can
do the utilization of hiv and flu at the
same time and if you can discover some
other antigens also so that is like a
broad neutralizing antibody what we call
in technical term on which people are
working on such uh
vaccine development program which can
generate such broad neutralizing
antibodies to in the human body which
can manage many pathogens as compared to
like we have specificity also but we
need the broadness also so this is the
kind of research that people are doing
which is broadening up the immunological
aspects of the vaccines i can say
now as i told that we are able to
multiplex
uh the cells
and then generate the data using the
cellplex assay so this is the data that
just generated from four samples so you
can see
uh adenocarcinomas muscle lung carcinoma
squamous cell carcinoma and lung cancer
a sample was there and you can see
multiplex and more tags that will be
that will be coming when we are doing uh
loading more number of cells but
ultimately we can filter out filter out
them from our data
so
first uh if you see
just uh demultiplexed the data is based
on the cell barcode so you can easily
and multiply the data into all the
antibodies or cell surface protein
markers around 17 markers were used
then you are able to see
the cell populations
so these are the various cell population
here is the name of those cell
population b cell dendritic monocytes
monocyte 16 n k
d double negative uh tc effector uh tc
memory atc name
th memory ts nave and undetermined so
this is like all the t cell population
if you see
and non small cellular carcinoma is
mostly uh b cell population is very high
which we are able to see here as
compared to rest of the other cancer and
in this
other
the undetermined
lung cancer you can see the t cell
population is very high that means this
is not a normal this is something else
which is evident from this particular
data set
and it is not also adenocarcinoma on
small stomach cell carcinoma so we have
more
detailed view of our sample i can say
when we are doing single cell technology
now as i told that
we are able to capture two type of data
from the same cell one is the
chromatin the attack data and other is
the gene expression data so here
this window if you see this window is
technically representing this data or
the gene expression data
and
why it is important i can say from this
group which is a b cell population which
is name and memory b cell
where they have the same explanation
pattern clustering together in this
window
whereas they are getting splitted into
the attack data into two
sample types based on the memory and the
name because the chromatin patterns is
different so ultimately it is giving
more power
to resolve the data
at different resolution and this pattern
if you say this pattern is coming for
the maturation of the t cell population
from the
native t cell population to the
nk cells or we can say other cell types
you are able to see a pattern of
chromatin
cell structures happening so attack data
gives you more pattern as compared to
the
cell expression data because that is
having a very
unique way of
promoting modification that is happening
at cell level
to generate or or to get the trajectory
of the cell populations
so this is going to help
uh interface free linking of
transcriptome and epigenome across
thousands of cells so instead of
having lot many mathematics stuff to be
done it can be done in a very simple and
easy way
and
this is also one of those window of our
software where you are able to see
all the cell population
which we are able to categorize
and then we have just chosen one ncm1
gene where you can see the promoter
signals in the last two or three cell
populations where you can see the
expression is happening
because of the promoter signal
and if there is some element here which
has like uh some uh bigger height
uh
in this upstream at
more than because this is morgan uh
because the mega bases away
and
you can just see the expression is very
very high in the last population
because they are there you can see more
number of this
this element is present in higher
uh
percentage we can say
and in the downstream also we have some
effectors so upstream and downstream
effectors were
found here and ultimately you can see
the expression was happening in these
cell types whereas
here is the inhibitory effect
where though you are getting the signal
of the promoter
but these elements have an arbitrary
effect and
that's why in this we have very limited
amount of gene expression
and where you don't have any expression
uh this element of ncm1 so these cell
also are not expressing the gene so you
need this to be
there uh
or captured or the cell has to be open
up for uh these ncm and promoter so that
gene expression can happen so in this
way you can
have more analysis of the data or or
you can find out whatever gene you are
working on how its negative elements are
arranged or captured
when we are doing the attack plus gene
expression workflow
in a more comprehensive way i can say
now
as i told that single-cell technology is
also
important for
tissue sections and
people are wanting to map the data to
the tissue location so why it is very
very important if you see these two
sections these two sections are
ultimately
the stained slides of two different
tumor and the red one and the blue one
the blue one is the tumor tumor and the
red one are the tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes so
if you see
from the top
image
these stills are moving inside are
entering inside the
the tumor and which is like important to
manage the disease
whereas
uh in the bottom one it is in the
periphery so that means our tills are
not entering in the tumor and tumor is
is like resistant to that particular uh
test so this is a poor prognosis so we
have to do some changes in the treatment
so that the test should enter in the
tumor space
now
with example i would like to say that
what type of data you are able to
generate so this is like some portion of
the paper you can uh refer it uh from a
slide
that
they have done some
uh reveal the special trajectory of the
non-small cell lung carcinoma so what
exactly they have done
so they took the tumor samples from
12 different patients and the category
was small cell lung carcinoma and
adenocarcinoma
and
then they did the tissue sections then
do the staining
capture the rna
generated the data do the clustering
part and ultimately uh whatever four
change of various genes were there that
was analyzed and also do the pseudo time
analysis so that they can do the
trajectory of the
various cancers uh spots that are moving
or uh
moving in that particular
tissue section
in this if you see
uh in this figure
this figure will be like uh
how many types of cells we captured so
first they categorize like
data is coming from what sample type so
only two colors you are able to see
the
and
you are able to see the orange one is
that you know carcinoma so almost there
clustering in this top one
whereas the small cell and carcinoma
having a one more different cluster so
that means there are some differences
and at the same time if you see the
number of cell types that we are able to
identify was almost 11
and you can see different clusters that
is there
the most important part is the
patient-wise when you do the
patient-wise
cell population analysis
you are able to see
like this one
uh the fourth one so it has its own cell
population
which is very much different from the
rest of the sample types so this means
these
cells or this patient have uniqueness in
terms of the gene expression of the cell
population that is happening
so that's why it is very very important
to understand or generate the data at
the single cell resolution or one to
tensor resolution so that
what is the real heterogeneity we can
understand
so this is very very important when we
are
trying to give the heterogeneity figure
of a particular or a picture to of a
particular sample
now
uh this is like the actual staining that
was done for
one two and four if you see one two
three i i've been showing the four one
is there
and where you can see in the four one
the cancer is moving to different
locations and the scans and stroma is
intermixed whereas in the
two and one
that sample it is at only one location
now
they
tried to dig out more information
from this sample
so they did the cancer in the stroma
study and they have just catalog gene
expression pattern of specific
genes that are responsible for
invasion migration
or
we can say cancer stages and everything
and they just catalog the heat maps so
if using the cancer one only
uh the heat map of the
those genes are totally different
um and because tumor micro environment
also regulates
so that's why you can see the very
different heterogeneity in this all the
four samples all the all the three
samples and the stroma oven also you can
see uh
the sample number two is behaving
differently from the cancer number four
or the cancer number one and similarly
you can see in that particular
all other genes also you will have a
different expression pattern so that
means uh our tumors are really very
heterogeneous at individual level
now
in this sample what they did
some surat clustering analysis of the
cancer areas
they also give in the med score uh that
will give you a
like
invasion efficiency of those
cells what is the efficiency
and tumor polarity means how many types
of cells are there in that particular
tumor so that also they were able to
figure it out from the same data
now from this you are able to see
from this
cancer 1
the pseudo root analysis they did and
they found out that one route there was
no branching happening or not movement
so this is confined to that location
only from from location two it has moved
to various location and ultimately this
one is leading to different other
locations so ultimately by understanding
this way
we are able to find out what exactly is
happening
at that cellular level
uh and gene expression level why it is
invasion migration is so much happening
and whether we can have a specific drug
to stop that migration
so that was like a small portion of the
publication but i will encourage
everyone to go through this publication
now
how exactly you have to do means what is
the real biochemistry behind it
so
since we are capturing data from the
tissue section so we need a slide
and if you see this particular slide has
four capture areas in which you will be
placing the tissue section and
ultimately you can have two options
either you can strain with hne
or you can strain with
immunofluorescence and ultimately
capture the image of the tissue then you
will follow steps to capture the rna
from this tissue section on the slide
itself
and ultimately you will be constructing
the library that is going to be
sequenced on the aluminum machine and
then once you analyze the data then you
will be using the loop browser to
visualize the data
now
uh
our slides are very very
specific
where you can see there is a 6.5 by 6.5
mm capture area
where the spots are there so almost 5000
spots are there and all these spots are
barcoded and the size of every spot is
55 micron and it has millions of primers
and each primer have a specific special
barcode the emi and the quality to
capture the rna and the partial read one
is part of illumina laboratory so we are
capturing the rna
from the tissue above the spot so
ultimately this barcode data is going to
map the data to the location on the
image of the tissue
now we have enabled it on a human and
mouse ffp section where by using probe
chemistry we are your synthetic poly a
probes are there which will be uh having
uh which will be specific to
all the 18 000 genes in human and 20 000
genes in mouse and using this synthetic
pro chemistry we are able to capture the
data
uh from the ffp samples so that will be
helping you to generate data for
biomarker discovery for the clinical
research and the normal and diseased uh
study can be done from the tissue
sections
now if you see the workflow differences
you want to see
the fresh frozen tissue
is directly happening uh the staining
and the imaging is happening here then
thermalization is happening to release
the rna
and then cdna sensor is happening on the
slide itself now the data is getting
barcoded or the molecules will be
barcoded and
once you prepare the
library you will map it to the location
the data on the tissue image in ffp
there is an intermediate step of
adding the pro vibrationalization step
then you will have rna treatment and
permeabilization one the pros will be
paralyzing and these synthetic probes
are getting captured and extended
and then ultimately we
sequence those extended probes and map
the data to the location of the tissue
this is the whole workflow uh of ffp and
fresh frozen so fresh frozen is a
typically one day workflow if you are
starting your uh ocd embedded tissue
sections
and ffpp is a two-day workflow where we
have overnight hybridization step that
has to be done and ultimately next day
you can just prepare the
samples and
you can construct the library and
sequence it on a lambda machine
so this is like
what exactly you will be able to do
uh when you are
using the ffpe so you will have the
complete view of the disease complexity
you will be able to do uh new biomarker
discoveries you will be able to
understand the novel cell types and
their states
and at the same time you can also so
through the
see the spatial organizations and use it
for creating the cell atlases
and spatial temporal gene expression
patterns can be easily
uh
easily
you can
do on a software part where with what
gene is expressed where you can just
figure it out just by searching the name
of the gene
and these are the slides you can see
actual slides that are being used to do
that
so
your bulk data is looking like this all
jumbled up
so
that has generated a lot of information
i can say right till date
but now people
use a new technology where they
segregate this data into a single cell
resolution and more neater
we can say and then figure it out what
is happening wrong in this very cell
population
then
still for the tissue people or tissue
lovers you want to map the data to the
location so this is the way uh our
technology is going to help to map it to
the location and now people are
combining these two data at the same
time uh to get more functional uh
aspects of the biology of a particular
tissue section uh so that
because right now it's not single cell
resolution once that we launched then uh
you can simply generate directly from
here
and this is being supported by both the
workflow that is the chromium workflow
and the region workflow from 10
astronomics
uh so these are like uh
where exactly
we are in the clinical space so you you
can do the high throughput target
screening you can do multimedia
characterization you can do cell type
and the substrate identification
the track the clonal behavior the car t
cell transgenic tcr that is right now
people are promising and doing this
therapy can be easily done and then
unbiased detection of antigen expression
now
this is just a summary i can say
so we are in the target discovery we are
in the cateration of infusion we can do
the response monitoring and we can do
resistance profiling using these
technologies
and at the same time
this is a whole summary i can see
we are in the chromium single set
technology and vision technology these
two technologies are in the discovery in
the translational phase people are using
it
now new technology is coming in
institute sequencing so in situ
sequencing is going to be uh integrated
microscopy based data generation
where multiple
data from the same tissue sample can be
generated so
the first two technologies is based on
ngs based data generation and this will
be independent technology that is going
to generate the data directly from the
section
using uh nc2 based sequencing method
so i'm happy to take
any questions and thank you very much
hope
i was able to
make you people understand about the
technology and how people are using it
so we are open for questions
thank you nitissa for the detailed
information
so here we have couple of questions
so the first question is do we need to
have trial information regarding cell
size before putting it in the machine
uh cell size in general yes people uh
have to like it should not be more than
30 40 micron and typically those cells
are in that
size
and if you have a challenge then you
will have to use the nuclei of the cells
if the cell is very big
then you have to work with the nuclei
i hope you have answered server your
question so the next one is can plural
fluid be prominent source for sample
collection for this kind of analysis
which fluid
neural fluid
neural fluid means any fluid which has
cells can be used
but from there you have to get the cell
and the debris debris is removed and
that can be used as
there has to be cell in that fluid
and you have a method to purify the
cells
or enrich the cells
so the next question is in certain
diseases where it is difficult to
extract cells from affected area how
should one go about it also what is the
minimum number of cells required for
effective data analysis in such cases
when your number of cell sample is very
very limited so
suppose you have 100 cells 200 cells or
like our lt kit is supporting
1000 cells so
1000 cells to load you need at least 3
000 self total sample so that limited
can be done and if it is very missed
in that way is like
at least minimum i will say 5000 cells
has to be there so that you can start
off your experiment
with very limited cells you can do
directly bulk data using some
low input rna kit
because
if you're not very much sure that you
will be able to do a live cell
suspension
then either try for vision technology
or
try to generate directly data from uh
some low input kit where
less number of samples can be handled
okay thank you tesla
let me check if there are any other
questions
other than tissue samples can store
cells
stored at minus 80 degree celsius can be
used for single cell analysis
though
because when we store cells in minus 18
rna later the rna is getting paralyzed
though rna remain intact but
our main purpose is to map the rna to
the individual cells
so
such cells are not recommended in a
leaky way
we need cell population which have
intact uh cell membranes and there
should not be any leakage of the rna
from uh
due to storage
which is expected when we store at minus
80.
so that is not recommended
10x is coming up with a kit where you
can fix the cells
for
up to seven days in four degree and you
can start your experiment once you
collect the cells
so there is one question who is
interested in uh minimal residual
decision hematology
the question is
from bone marrow point of view it's high
heterogeneity what is the accuracy that
is followed
accuracy that is followed uh
in terms of
if you say the rare cell population we
can pick it up
we are capturing all the rna data of
individual cells so you are getting the
complete story it is not based on very
specific marker we miss out something so
so the story is complete i will say we
are giving a complete picture of the
sample from there we can figure it out
what cell type populations are there in
that heterogeneous sample so
uh we i can say that uh instead of using
10 marker 20 marker or 100 markers i am
giving the complete story of the samples
what exactly various cells are and what
genes they are expressing so it will be
a complete story instead of a very
small story using 10 marker or 20 marker
followed by that there is a one question
more what is the minimum sample needed
minimum sample as i told for single cell
workflow you need at least 5000 cell has
to be there because you need some qc and
other stuff
uh
that will be the starting point i can
say because
even if you want to profile 1000 cells
at least 3000 cell has to be there with
you
so the next question is is there any
screening criteria if we get huge number
of cell types how to categorize them
how to categorize them uh if you having
a lot many samples you are profiling the
software is going to help
to
use the
like clustering is happening automated
way so it is not like user determined
but there will be some software that is
going to help you
but once you search like marker gene
analysis because first is clustering is
happening randomly so that is we are not
controlling it is software driven uh and
then you search the specific cluster
what gene they are expressing
so because the table will be there in
the software the loop browser you can go
so that will let you know what are the
top gene expression happening in that
particular population then you're able
to figure out like what cell type it is
based on those gene expression pattern
so
number of cells is not a limit or any
any issue will be there ultimately there
should be a heterogeneity if it is the
same sample they will be clustered
together and if they are different
sample they will be clustering in the
different clusters
okay
so the next question is what all
parameters are checked in single cell qc
what all parameters are checked in
single cell qc number one the cell uh
debris has not to be there the viability
has to be above 80 85
the total count has to be there you
should be aware that
the temperature should not do the
clumping of the cells
and
the right type of media that you want to
process it
there should not be any
rnas activity of a particular cell
population so that's why you need some
specific modifications because if the
cells are like neutrophils which have
rnas activity
that will degrade the rna during the
sample preparation only so those things
we have to consider
all together
the next question is people want to know
the quantity how much ml minimum
quantity is needed to start the process
i guess
oh
that is like
if you have like a 1000
or 500
cells per microliter then at least 50
microliter cell i will say 50 micro
samples will be sufficient
even 100 microliter 50 100 micrometer so
it is the number of cell is more
important because you can just pin down
and enrich make the stock concentrated